Hey so today we're going to create a
JavaScript 3d World in five minutes give
or take have you been following this
channel you'll know that you can do some
pretty cool stuff in 3d with JavaScript
it's not limited to just crap like cubes
and simple shapes we've built entire
world's made cool space battles and even
wrote a Minecraft clone but we all got
to start somewhere so today let's take a
step back and make a simple 3d world in
JavaScript what we'll do today is put
together a little world with some moving
stuff and we'll have a nice background
pretty similar to what I use as starting
point for my projects starting with a
blank slate here what I'm doing here is
creating the directory and the
index.html file then we can go ahead and
load everything up in the editor we'll
use three j/s which is a great wrapper
library around WebGL I highly recommend
it so that's what this import up here
does there's a bit of setup here that we
need to go through so let's go line by
line here this line sets up the WebGL
renderer which is what displays
everything on the screen and now it's
add a few parameters here like I want
shadows and so we enable this and choose
soft blurry ones because they look nice
we also need to tell 3GS a bit about the
screen size and all that stuff now
there's a couple other things you need a
camera so we'll create a perspective
camera this is like an abstraction over
a real camera so when you move this
around your scene it's like a movie
director moving the camera around next
we create a scene which is like a
container for all the objects in our 3d
world and the last thing we need is some
lighting so I'll make one directional
light with shadows and then some ambient
light for the rest of the scene and
you'll notice here on this line that I
add it to the scene right now this code
does nothing on its own so we need to
make a render function and call it using
requestanimationframe these lines do
that we can call requestanimationframe
with this callback and then in the
callback we render and call
requestanimationframe again to start the
process over for the next frame so at
this point we've done a whole lot of
nothing bunch of setup but that's about
it
next step is adding a skybox using us
cube map so let's go to Google here and
then type in free sky boxes and as you
can see there's a ton of options here
I've gone ahead and downloaded one
already I've got
the sides of the cube texture here and
with a few lines of code we can load
these up and assign them to the
background quick aside for everyone who
doesn't know a cube map is just a
special version of a texture but with
six sides one for each face of the cube
and you sample it using a direction
vector instead of the typical UV
coordinates anyway so we load the cube
map here now we load up the project and
you can spin around and look in every
direction and we've got the static sky
image up this is just a facade though we
haven't actually made anything just the
appearance of a world but it's just that
an appearance
so let's actually add some 3d elements
to the world to do that we need just a
few lines of code so we'll instantiate a
plain geometry and a material and then
we need to create a mesh using that
geometry in the material just a few
parameters to set and make it receive
shadows spin it to face up and then this
last line adds it to the scene and voila
we've got a plane it could be the ground
for example now back in code let's go
add some more things to the world
so we'll instantiate a box geometry and
again create a material and a mesh set
its position and then add it to the
scene in the world now you have this box
here and that's it that's how you can
get started making your own 3d world in
JavaScript if this was helpful let me
know codes all available on github so I
encourage you definitely go and grab it
fork it play with it add some things to
it tell me what you did do whatever you
want with it and I'll see you next time
Cheers